niccolò machiavelli
probably one of the most highly
acclaimed philosophers and political
theories of all time
also one of my greatest influences and a
figure has been referenced quoted and
misunderstood like few but before I
initiate my attempt scrutinize
Machiavelli and his philosophy I want to
ask you a question when somebody
mentions the name Machiavelli or the
terms
Machiavelli inand Machiavelli anism what
is the first thing that comes to your
mind I assume that you think of words
like dark triad duplicity and
manipulation or in a broader context the
ability to gain power through deception
and sincerity and abuse of power
actually those are all wrong
they do play a role in the way
Machiavelli expressed his political
theories but they all failed to paint an
accurate picture of a man if there is a
word that could accurately describe
Machiavelli and his ideas it is this
pragmatism he was probably the first
political theorist escaped the delusion
of idealism and honestly proposed
pragmatic solutions and deportations of
government apparently his views were
dramatically influenced by the time he
lived in and his personal experiences
often times exceeding the threshold of
political correctness and blurring the
lines between morally right and morally
wrong nonetheless they constitute the
powerful compendium of knowledge that
the shaping the interpretation of power
and influence till this very day
Nicolo de Bernardo de Machiavelli was
born in 1469 in Florence Italy his
family was descended from the older
rulers of Tuscany and they have produced
many members that were part of the
government of the time back then
Italy consisted of many city-states that
were usually ruled by different houses
Florence was among the largest
city-states in Europe and was considered
one of the wealthiest and most
successful part of the success should be
attributed to the house of Medici which
was one of the strongest families of the
time the Medici controlled the Medici
bank then Europe's largest bank and this
allowed them to expand their influence
and strategic alliances in 1494 after a
popular revolt the Medici were exposed
from power in Florence was restored to a
republic it was then that Machiavelli
received his first government role as
the person responsible for the
production of official Florentine
government documents Machiavelli was
part of a government that wanted to
liberate Florence from the Medici reign
but that was far from easing the Medici
had the strong alliance with a pope and
the recapture of Florence was a matter
of time Machiavelli career was quite
turbulent and ended sadly in 1512
when he was deprived of office after the
Medici won a critical battle that helped
him emerged power once again in 1513 the
Medici accused Machiavelli of conspiracy
against them and had him imprisoned and
tortured after denying involvement he
was released and decided to retire to
his estate at san andreas ena in order
to devote himself to studying and
writing that's when he completed his
seminal works the prince and
courses and that's when he gained his
reputation as a great political theorist
and a philosopher when Machiavelli
turned to the question of whether it is
better for a prince to be loved or
feared he stated that while it would be
wonderful for a leader to be both he
should eventually side with fear
Machiavelli suggests that human nature
is somewhat ungrateful fickle and
assembling the prince or any person in
power is like the authority figure that
substitutes the parent figure when the
person enters adulthood
people in power will always have a huge
responsibility toward their followers
this responsibility creates a form of
dependency that urges people to keep
craving more and keep holding the prince
accountable for most of their needs such
an intense interplay damages most of the
ability to cultivate self-reliance and
people instead of appreciating the
princes offerings they usually become
more ungrateful and keep asking for more
therefore a prince needs to resemble
characteristics that don't allow others
to question his authority SATA
characteristic is fear fear although it
still creates a dependency between the
ruler and the people it successfully
prevents unwanted behaviors stemming
from lack of appreciation
the trick here is to ensure that fear
doesn't really turn into hatred intense
cruel and unjustified demonstrations of
fear can never keep people engaged fear
needs to be subtle induced in a way that
people can justify it the events of
punishment should be subject to
convincing reasoning for people will
side with the most persuasive argument
in Chapter 15 of the Prince Machiavelli
states the following men have imagined
Republic's and the principalities that
never really existed at all yet the way
men live is so far removed from the way
they ought to live that anyone who
abandons what is for what should be
pursues his downfall rather his
preservation for the man who strives
after goodness
in all his acts is sure to come to ruin
since there are so many men who are not
good in this passage Machiavelli exudes
the totality of his pragmatic ideals he
exposes the reality of human nature and
explains that being constantly nice will
get you nowhere because most people are
not that nice
in short he tries to explain that a
prince should destroy the delusion that
acting good will always favor him but at
the same time create the illusion that
he's actually good for people respect
goodness
[Music]
in general some personal characteristics
will earn people praise others
condemnation courage compassion faith
craftiness and generosity number among
the qualities that receive praise
cowardice cruelty stubbornness and
miserliness are usually met with
condemnation ideally a prince would
possess all the qualities deemed good by
others but this expectation is
unrealistic
the princes first job is to safeguard
the state and Alice harboring bad
characteristics is sometimes necessary
for this end the relationship between
the prince and the people is quite a
turbulent one people demand actions but
at the same time they're not ready to
react maturely to difficult situations
in order to understand the impact this
dynamic has in the relationship we need
to work with an analogy think of a
difficult romantic relationship we had
after the honeymoon face reality hits
you hard and most times one of the
parties will let their mask of sanity
slip false expectations neurotic
reactions unmet needs and increased
familiarity will lead to friction and an
inability to maintain a stable
connection despise your more courageous
attempts to be honest your partner keeps
reacting negatively to news that don't
suit the liking your ability to
communicate honest views decreases with
time and inevitably you become dishonest
in order to avoid conflict in a romantic
relationship usually you have the luxury
to live but a prince doesn't wish to
abandon his position he decides to
embrace dishonesty as the most effective
weapon to deal with lack of conflict
people will almost always favor a
delusional hope to a harsh truth
in Chapter six to nine of the Prince
Machiavelli explains what a prince needs
to do after he acquires his position
depending on the way he ascended to
power the overarching theme of this idea
is that loyalty needs to be constantly
scrutinized and bought and resistance to
be crushed when it comes to loyalty the
people who decide to be on the princes
side will do so because they can benefit
from him and not because they actually
like him they're bound to the prince and
their loyalty is a matter of character
and benefits the prince needs to ensure
that their rapacious and overly
ambitious shouldn't be trusted
and that the weak spirited and grateful
should be sought after and constantly
praised that is a sake but create detail
to identify overly ambitious people can
stay loyal for long there are also
thirsty for power and eventually will
try and sabotage those above them in
contrast people who are weak spirited
will always savor the relationship with
the prince because it allows them to
feel safe and that they belong to his
tribe when it comes to resistance
Machiavelli recognizes resistance as an
omnipresent force that is because people
are naturally resistant to change and
reform especially people who benefited
from the old order we resist fiercely
Prince's who keep the old order around
will inevitably need to keep fighting
them and that suggests waste of time
resources and trust ergo people who
resist need to be crashed on a whim and
fast so that the prince can focus on
reassuring the followers of the strength
of the new order and the benefits that
will follow
in chapter 25 Machiavelli tries to
conclude his ideas with a main strategy
to be followed by countries and
individuals in order to increase their
chances of success free will versus
determinism has always been a hot topic
among thinkers Machiavelli stance on the
matter is again very pragmatic according
to him success is the point where
preparation meets opportunity
a person cannot control the world but he
can definitely control most of his
actions through foresight people conceal
themselves against misfortune and
self-sabotage moreover because damn
changes the Prince needs to adopt and
embrace malleable characteristics on the
whole impetuosity surpasses caution and
fortune favours energetic youth
overcautious age Machiavellian tactics
and strategies might come across as
quite caustic and even dangers for some
for me his works are invariably imbued
with a sense of awe and they constitute
a combustible body of knowledge actually
the prince is suggested in most
political science programs around the
world as a must-read this is not by
accident
those principles have been espoused and
applied by the most successful political
figures of our path and are present
knowing and eventually understanding
those principles can be a crucial step
forwards in redressing the balance
within ourselves and eventually within
our political system
hi everyone this video was something I
was really looking forward to creating
that's not only because my cam Valley is
one of the thinkers that have influenced
my worldview but also because I wanted
to shed some light on some
misconceptions that tend to be
associated with him and his philosophy
additionally in our current epoch where
politics are not considering anymore
this elusive concept that seems so
far-fetched and so abstract but more
like a skill with certain mechanics that
can be construed and cultivated it is
our duty to look into its mechanics in
order to understand the extent to which
we can influence it and as a result
improve and evolve our political system
as always if you enjoyed this video make
sure to like it share it with people
that you think will benefit from it and
if you haven't done so already subscribe
and hit the notification button so you
can be informed when I will release my
next video finally I encourage you to
express yourself in the comment section
below but please do so in a civil way
and check out my social media profiles
and all my ebooks in the description of
this video thanks again for watching
take care